dennis franz valli noah battue c'est mal
parti
élection 500 signatures beaucoup de
petits candidats sont encore loin du
compte
l'espagne après le coup d'état raté
franquisme sa mort font enquête le
bernard benyamin et genre eh bien
messieurs bonsoir invité d'honneur de ce
journal jean baptiste poquelin 722 773
premiers rôles fils de tapissier dernier
rôle
argan dans le malade imaginaire c'est
ariane mnouchkine qui a donc invité
molière à partager vos soirées tout de
suite après le journal
à partir de ce soir cinq épisodes une
vie de molière qui devrait vous
passionner et puis deuxième entrée en
matière avant de pénétrer de plain pied
dans l'actualité la couleur du temps
laurent broomhead oui bien
malheureusement patrick nous nous
préparons un week-end de humide si vous
avez une girouette en haut de votre
maison sur le clocher voisin qui a vous
découvrez que le vent vient de l'ouest
du sud-ouest l'air humide arrive sur le
pays avec des vagues depuis la première
c'était aujourd'hui une autre ce sera
dimanche avec entre les des biens des
pluies plus abondantes au nord de la
loire avec cette humilité bien il y à un
redoux et regarder les températures
relevées aujourd'hui à 13h par les
stations de la météorologie nationale
les voici voyez elles sont douces à peu
près partout saut dans l'extrême est du
pays où le redoux arrivera seulement
demain avec également quelques pluies la
carte maintenant de prévisions pour
demain
voyez que d'abord dans le sud est du
pays et bien deserces sur la corse puis
du soleil c'est la carte ceci à peu près
à midi al'inverse de l'autre côté côté
de la bretagne de la vendée de la
normandie beaucoup de nuages et des
pluies intermittentes faibles en général
mais tout de même désagréables partout
ailleurs à ciel souvent nuageux ou très
nuageux des pluies qui se localiseront
tout de même principalement au nord de
la loire et des éclaircies plus belles
dans les régions plus au sud
disons dans le midi toulousain en
particulier maintenant un mot des
températures moyennes qui seront relevés
sans doute demain voyez le minimum entre
6 et 8 devrait à peu près partout le
maximum entre 10 et 17 degrés dans le
sud s'est élevé pour la saison enfin un
mot du temps
de dimanche et bien malheureusement une
nouvelle vague de pluie arrivera des
faibles pluies mais désagréable tout de
même si tu es le matin de la vendée à
l'alsace elles progresseront dans la
journée vers le sud-ouest pour atteindre
le soir les pyrénées et les alpes est
précédé de soleil dans le sud est et
suivi de quelques sites la cible aussi
d'averses dans le nord ouest
ce n'est pas très sympathique que les
tennismen français australiens n'ont vu
cet après-midi ni soleil ni pluie à lyon
il jouait sur court couvert et pour
l'instant ça nous réussit pas trop
français dans le premier simple au terme
d'un match passionnant
yannick noah l'atout maître des français
a été battu par le numéro un australien
mcnamara est en ce moment même
pascal porte et c'est de faire
contrepoids contre edmonton avec alain
tolère la défaite de noah dont le
premier set noah déterminer plus
puissant des bornes mcnamara et
l'emportent 6 4 l'australien réplique
dès le deuxième set grâce à un jeu de
fond de court qui insensiblement
déstabilise nos à l'australien se
détache 5 2 noah courageux revient à 5
partout mais mc namara remporte 7 8 6 au
troisième set
noah accumule les erreurs l'australien
est supérieur il conclue 6-3
quatrième set après le repos yannick
noah commence par perdre son service
puis gagne 7 à l'énergie 6 3 dans le
cinquième
après plus de quatre heures de match le
français s'incline 3 6 une défaite qui
entame les chances de qualification de
la france
voilà donc demain le doublé puis
peut-être avant la fin de ce journal
résultat du match dont deux portent
contre edmonton deuxième grand événement
sportif france gall en rugby un
engouement populaire exceptionnelle 120
mille demandes de places pour 55 milles
seulement possibilité au parc des
princes on n'avait jamais vu ça
un phénomène qu'a voulu analyser pierre
salviac ils sont cinquante mille
soixante mille soixante dix mille même
c'est selon les stades
il leur arrive souvent d'être ivre de
bière ou de vin des corbières ses
supporteurs passionnés et fidl font du
tournoi une grande fête populaire
même les joueurs s'interrogent devant ce
phénomène de société qui remplit les
stades les pubs et les salons où trône
la télévision grâce au tournoi
le rugby est devenu un grand spectacle
de partout on accourt pour être de la
fête
pour expliquer ce succès des sociologues
prétendent que le tournoi est un bon
prétexte au défoulement des masses il
doit bien y avoir d'autres raisons tout
aussi que le rugby est un sport très
télégénique et que
ces événements successifs ces matchs que
que vous montrez un autre équipe
britannique qui avec une foule
extraordinaire autour avec des chambres
avec une ambiance et nous remettre tout
ça fait que le rugby est un sport qui
qu'effectivement les mérites être
populaire avec le tournoi c'est la
guerre de cent ans qui trouve son
prolongement
pas étonnant dans ces conditions que la
france se mobilise le samedi à 15 heures
derrière qu'un ce type courageux
d'ailleurs fière et patriotes qui lui
promettent à chaque match auto de
revanche sur l'histoire prendre cela en
particulier attire beaucoup plus de
monde que les autres matches le tour des
six nations et en particulier pour
france gall jeu comme il est de
constater avec plaisir d'un côté à
l'arrivée de l'autre que semble exagéré
nous avons environ 120 1000e place de
vendée pour un stade qu'elle confiait 50
me elle s'est ainsi en particulier que
encore ce matin nous avons reçu el
sheikh hamdan de suisse pour assister la
rendent compte que nous sommes obligés
de renvoyer puisque malheureusement nous
n'avons plus aucune place disponible
quelques jours avant la rentrée pour les
son billet les sans piston est refoulé
du parc
il reste la télé avec la voix de couderc
et d'alves et là des jo
d'après les sondages un téléspectateur
sur quatre gardes le match
un jour nikita khrouchtchev en visite
dans le sud ouest à défiler dans un
désert de pau halak à cette heure-là
le tournoi se jouait sur les petits
écrans
et bien chaque fois qu'il y à un match
du tournoi des cinq nations télévisée
nous constatons deux choses premièrement
à une baisse des ventes pendant la
période
pendant le temps la durée du match que
ce soit d'ailleurs un match où l'équipe
de france participe non c'est donc un
phénomène purement tournoi des cinq
nations
les ventes sont reportés d'une manière
générale avant le match ou après en
second lieu le samedi est
traditionnellement un réservé aux achats
de coupe et nous constatons que pendant
la durée du match
ce sont souvent des femmes seules qui
font leurs courses bien souvent les
maris les accompagnent d repartent chez
eux
c'est un monde d'hommes et que peut-être
c'est une façon de s'échapper de la
maison c'est un prétexte ou quelquefois
pour les garçons de se réunir dans une
vie de garçon toujours quand ils vont à
paris par exemple pour le grand match
il rentre dans cette vie de garçon
malgré la crise 7000 gallois seront dans
cette rue du parc des princes un réseau
d'une livre par semaine ils ont
économisé pendant deux ans l'argent du
voyage à paris rendez vous donc à 15
heures demain sur antenne 2 avec roger
couderc et pierre albaladejo
reste ensuite une rencontre le match
contre l'angleterre le 21 mars à tucana
mais là aussi ça démarre très fort dans
les demandes de billets à tel point
qu'on vient de découvrir que vingt mille
faux tickets de cette horde ce style
vous voyez venait d'être imprimé sans
doute à londres c'est la fédération
anglaise de rugby qui a alerté scotland
yard qui a remonté la filière mais ne
vous inquiétez pas si vos billets
proviennent des fédérations il n'y a pas
de problème méfiez vous quand même de
toute proposition de ventes parallèles
méfiez vous des contrefaçons cela nous
amène directement à la politique
depuis hier les maires et les
conseillers généraux et les
parlementaires sont en possession des
fameux formulaire qui leur permettent de
parrainer les futurs candidats pour ce
qu'on appelle les grands pas de problème
mais les autres sont à l'affût qui
pourra se présenter une première
estimation de pyrale
les 38 1635 élus habilité à présenter un
candidat vont donc maintenant devoir
remplir le formulaire officiel
hormis les quatre grands candidats et
ceux qui comme michel debré et michel
crépeau appartiennent à des formations
politiques représentées à l'assemblée
qui peut espérer obtenir les 500
signatures dans les conditions prévues
par la loi
sept des quelques 35 petits candidats
ont une chance ou en tout cas affirme
avoir obtenu au moins le nombre requis
de promesses de signatures dans l'ordre
alphabétique
huguette bouchardeau ps eu 650 coluche
650 marie france garaud chiffres non
communiqué alain krivine ligue
communiste révolutionnaire 533 arlette
laguiller lutte ouvrière 500 jean marie
le pen front national chiffres non
communiqué bertrand renouvin nouvelle
action royaliste 500 deux autres petits
candidats auront certainement du mal à
atteindre la barre des 500 brice lalonde
écologistes 300 promesses actuellement
roger garaudy écrivain 250
il ne s'agit que de promesses de
signatures
on sera le 8 avril si elles sont
confirmées
si les prétendants se montre optimiste
il ne faut pas s'attendre cependant à ce
qu'il y ait plus qu'une dizaine de
candidats en définitive alors dans les
candidats actuellement lice une nouvelle
dégradation de la cote de confiance de
valeilles saab est un avant sa
déclaration de candidature 41% des
français lui font confiance 55% ne lui
font pas confiance je suis aussi de
l'image de raymond barre si on parle
popularité maintenant jacques chirac et
françois mitterrand sont en hausse de 4
points 4 points que père michel debré
pierre mauroy en gagne 3 et georges
marchais 1
enfin 55% des français approuvent la
candidature giscard 22% la désapprouvent
quant au jugement sur sa passation de
lundi moitié moitié en bref maintenant
le commandant cousteau au soutien brice
lalonde il a adressé une lettre en ce
sens aux maires de france jacques chirac
lui est soutenu par 133 parlementaire et
puis le socialiste jacques attali
affirmé ce matin sur europe 1 que sous
un septennat mitterrand on pourrait
créer deux à trois millions d'un point
françois mitterrand qui aujourd'hui
encore était en allemagne avec son ami
willebrand pour remonter un petit peu le
chemin de son évasion il y à tout juste
40 ans de cela
françois mitterrand qui avait fait à
l'époque 600 km en à pied avant d'être
repris à la frontière suisse et à la
troisième tentative d'évasion il a enfin
pu gagner londres la femme l'année 41
aujourd'hui ce pèlerinage prévu depuis
longtemps avait un caractère privé aucun
rapport avec la campagne et orale en
france a souligné françois mitterrand
françois mitterrand qui participera
cartes sur table le 16 mars georges
marchais le 23 valeo destin valéry
giscard d'estaing le 30
et puis jacques chirac lundi prochain un
dernier mot sur la campagne
présidentielle les polémiques se
poursuivent au sein de la cgt sa
direction a condamné les déclarations de
cinq de ses responsables de bedian
socialiste qui estimait que la cgt était
en ce moment confisquée par le pc et
deux autres responsables cégétistes
jacqueline lambert et rené bull qui
déclare n'appartenir à aucun bord
politique précis on regrettait ses
rivalités politiques actuellement au
sein la cgt transports un petit peu ce
syndicat en champ clos de rivalités
politiques et d'accusations réciproques
à l'étranger d'abord cette très belle
enquête de bernard benyamin et de genres
et tous deux sont restés en espagne
après le putsch pour les est de savoir
jusqu'où aller les racines de cette
contestation de droite en espagne et ils
ont découvert que dans bien des coeurs
franco n'était pas mort loin de là
il s'appelle rossé luis et il a 24 ans
depuis deux ans il est commis livreur
dans une petite entreprise
d'alimentation des environs de madrid
ils viennent l'équivalent de 2800 francs
par mois environ et ne s'en plaint pas
il faut dire qu'un million 600 mille
espagnols sont aujourd'hui au chômage 12
% de la population active
tous les syndicats de la filiale
morimoto politique c'est la salle entre
le capital et le guide pour que c'est
sans doute la leçon un peu trop bien
apprise des membres de la phalange mais
elle surprend quand même lorsque l'on à
24 ans que l'on travaille dans une
banlieue ouvrière de madrid vallier
casse où le parti communiste a fait le
plein des voix aux dernières élections
municipales
lorsque l'on vit dans un pays où la
démocratie retrouvée et célébrer
quotidiennement cette profession de foi
d'un militant qui se réclame aujourd'hui
de la droite espagnole demande des
explications procès luis aller nous les
donner en nous conduisant chez ses
parents qui tiennent un petit bar
restaurant à bali ex
son père d'abord 51 ans trop jeune pour
avoir participé à la guerre d'espagne il
avait 8 ans l'époque les assez vieux
pour se souvenir de la mort de ses trois
frères tombés contre les rouges
militants de la première heure
admirateur du car audio il a élevé son
fils dans le respect de ses convictions
et la poussie plus tard à rejoindre les
rangs de la phalange sa mère ensuite
qu'ils fassent à journée devant ses
fourneaux et qui regrette tellement les
années sans souci du franquisme
dans ces conditions procès luis avait un
itinéraire politique tout tracé et c'est
ainsi que deux ou trois soirs par
semaine il retrouve ses camarades de la
fal ans tombé dans l'oubli au lendemain
de la mort de franco le mouvement est en
train de renaître grâce aux jeunes grâce
à ces petits commerçants chauffeur de
taxi ou employés de bureau qui
déchantent de la vie politique espagnole
devant l'impuissance de leurs élus à
régler les problèmes
ils font l'amalgamé entre démocratie et
crise économique rejette tout en bloc et
s'en prennent à regretter l'ancien temps
surtout au lendemain du coup d'état les
cortès a cherché à mettre en application
l'accord reach nintendo des solutions et
marque roxy boys in mové système de tarn
était calme et isolé comme il paraît
bonheur de chanter ma ma santé res
publica et des maximes et d'espagne en
premier poteau et les stéroïdes et se
référer ce talent l aurais tu n'aimais
pas ça fait mouche en est il noté
c'est clair la droite espagnole réclame
un vrai chef
un nouveau cas hold you et elle ne rate
pas une occasion de le rappeler ici à
valladolid
moins d'une semaine après le coup d'état
à l'occasion de l'anniversaire de la
mort du premier phalangistes fuseliers
au début de la guerre d'espagne
je
à lire à part
de toute évidence ce renouveau de la
droite espagnole issus des masses
populaires existent même s'il est encore
faible mais il prend chaque jour un peu
plus d'importance tant il est vrai que
les habitudes et les mentalités forgée
au cours de quarante ans de franquisme
ne se perdent pas si facilement c'est
vrai pour la phalange mais c'est vrai
surtout pour la police la garde civile
dans une moindre mesure pour l'armée où
la paris franquiste est resté en place
bref pour tous et par qui le danger peut
t'arriver
la soirée est libre
un très grave attentat cet après midi en
plein centre de la ville de zahlé dans
le centre du pays trois personnes ont
été tuées et 22 autres blessés par
l'explosion d'une voiture piégée
une conférence de presse de ronald
reagan en ce moment même depuis un petit
quart d'heure c'est la deuxième de sa
présidence s'il apporte des éléments
essentiels nous le dirons aussitôt bien
entendu
en attendant il ya ce jugement qui va
être à son tour commenté ce jugement de
raymond barre sur le ragga nisme
appliqué à la france il était
aujourd'hui à lyon et en a parlé devant
le centre de pêche vous les affaires le
choix d' examiner si le programme
économique proposé par la nouvelle
administration américaine est totalement
convaincant je vous dirais que je
m'interroge moi même comme économiste
sur la vraie portée de la théorie de
l'offre selon laquelle il suffirait
d'alléger les impôts et les contrôles et
de réduire les dépenses publiques pour
que la production s'accroît ce que la
hausse des prix se modèrent et que le
chômage recule mais ça apparemment c'est
une pierre dans le jardin du maire de
paris
en attendant les américains aujourd'hui
sont surtout passionné pour un
détournement d'avion qui s'est terminée
de blizzard façon à los angeles un à un
les otages ont été relâchés ou se sont
échappés le pirate de l'air s'est
retrouvé tout seul dans l'avion et puis
s'est rendu est pas autre chose à faire
en revanche un autre détournement
d'avion qui se passe mal à kaboul c'est
l'un des plus longs de l'histoire
peut-être même le plus long dans l'avion
de l'ata qui se marrent lines bloqué en
afghanistan par trois pirates de l'air
il ya déjà eu un mort
le président afghan babrak karmal a
lancé un appel au calme aux pirates de
l'air l'un d'eux a promis de se rendre à
ces exigences
il y encore 115 flottage dans l'appareil
le naufrage du tanio c'était il ya un an
tout juste mais aujourd'hui encore
malgré les temps des plongeurs 8000
tonnes de brut repose toujours fond de
la mer
dans les flancs du bateau quand on
commande l'amoco cadiz il a été lui
autoriser à re naviguer ce qui a
profondément choqué les bretons et
surtout les communes sinistrées
ainsi en ont décidé les libériens
puisque nous parlons de la mer sachez
que le ministre la défense robert gates
a assisté à un exercice de lutte anti
sous marine au large de lorient à une
trentaine de milles de la côte c'était
sa première visite au phosphore
d'opérationnel de la marine et il avait
pu observer une opération simulé de
chasse aux sous marins à bord de la
frégate dû détruire et de l'escorteur
casabianca la tentative d'attentât
contre jacques fauvet revendiqué par une
organisation delta organisations
politiques d'extrême droite qui tire son
nom des commandos delta pendant la
guerre d'algérie et pull enquête sur la
mort de carole simon
il semble que les dernières auditions de
son amie d'origine laotienne tendent à
le mettre hors de cause sur place à la
pj françois connaît la garde à vue du
témoin numéro un dans la sphère de la
faculté de médecine est terminée
le laotien interrogé depuis jeudi
dernier par les policiers de la brigade
criminelle a quitté libre tout à l'heure
le quai des orfèvres par une porte
dérobée
son interrogatoire n'a apporté aucun
élément nouveau à l' enquête les
policiers l'avaient appréhendé vous en
souvenez jeudi dernier à son retour de
bangkok
il voulait lui poser quelques questions
sur les contradictions relevées dans son
emploi du temps du 22 et 23 décembre
dernier
ils voulaient l'interroger également sur
le fait qu'ils n'étaient allait
vraisemblablement voir son ami embaumeur
à la faculté de médecine
or le lait aussi a déclaré qu'il n'était
jamais allé à la faculté de médecine
qu'il n'avait pas revu son ami embaumeur
depuis cinq mois et qu'il n'était jamais
entrée dans les salles de dissection la
sphère repart donc à zéro
elle est loin d'être terminée et puis
les douaniers français anglais ont
arraisonné hier après-midi un cargo
panaméen chargé trois tonnes de cannabis
son capitaine et son équipage des
hollandais et des belges sont gardés à
vue par la police anglaise dans le port
de new haven regardez bien ces impacts
que vous allez découvrir deux balles de
mitrailleuses sur la coque et les
superstructures il y en a une bonne
centaine
c'est ce qui m'a fait sursauter c'est un
escorteur français la perte usan qui a
tiré sur le cargo encore une vaste des
taux d'intérêt en france mais cette fois
ci le pendule revient un peu à la baisse
on passe de 13% à 12 75% ce qui est
quand même super héros à ce qui se
passait au début de l'année par hasard
et puisque nous parlons d'argent j'ai
dans les mains sans doute l'argent de
demain on utilisera de moins en moins de
liquide mais de plus en plus de cartes
de crédit de ce style mais on ira plus
loin que l'actuel utilisation pendant
trois jours des banquiers viennent
d'imaginer l'avenir a monté carl clip du
maire était avec la cette dame est en
train de rentrer dans sa banque à l'aide
d'une simple carte magnétique
il faut dire que ce guichet automatique
peut se trouver n'importe où un câble le
relie à la banque centrale et cela
permet à notre client d'effectuer la un
bon nombre d'opérations retirer de
l'argent bien sûr avoir un état de son
compte ou commandes et un carnet de
chèques des banques pourront même offrir
grâce à ces machines des services
annexes telles que l'adresse d'une
blanchisserie ou le film du cinéma le
plus proche
certains constructeurs ont développé
toutes les possibilités offertes par
l'électronique en permettant par exemple
de faire un dépôt de chèques ou d'argent
même avec des vieux billets ce guichet
automatique offre aussi d'être presque
toujours disponible même si la banque
est fermée récemment un dirigeant d'une
grande banque française a estimé qu' à
peine 6 % du personnel de son
établissement se consacrait à
l'enregistrement des transactions par
exemple de retraits d'espèces en
conséquence
l'appareil les automates bancaires qui
sont installés à l'heure actuelle dans
leurs fonctions retraits d'espèces ne
serait en aucun cas diminuer le
personnel de son établissement mais au
contraire lui permettre de se consacrer
à des tâches beaucoup plus intéressant
ce n'est pas l'avis de tout le monde
mais il faut bien admettre que certaines
tâches ne sont pas faciles dans le
commerce notamment où les nombreux
produits pourraient être plus facilement
comptabiliser les machines actuelles
sont souvent encore un peu compliqué et
demandent des manipulations que seul un
spécialiste peut effectuer
il existe également des moyens beaucoup
plus simple et beaucoup plus pratique
pour vous en particulier cette pompe à
essence ou là il vous suffit simplement
d'une carte de crédit
regardez vos l'introduisait dans la
machine
la machine va vous demander votre code
34 29
en l'occurrence vous reprenez votre
carte
elle vous dit servez vous une fois que
votre fenêtre vous leur posez ici et la
machine vous demande si vous voulez un
ticket alors à ce moment-là ou de ce qui
sera un bouton et s'est terminée la
banque
ce chercheur a de tout le reste mais
vous avez toujours la possibilité
d'avoir un contrôle il est difficile de
dire qui du banquier ou du clients
profitent le plus de ces nouveaux
systèmes
si la carte magnétique remplace bientôt
le chèque ce sera peut être simplement
plus facile pour tout le monde
voilà j'avais promis de vous donner deux
informations pendant le courant de ce
journal tout d'abord il faut savoir
qu'en tennis parce qu'elle porte et
warwick warwick et non pas une seule
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure sont à
égalité un set partout je vous rappelle
que noah lui a été battu dans la
première manche contre l'australie il a
été battu par mcnamara et puis deuxième
information les premiers propos de
ronald reagan pendant sa conférence de
presse nous venons à l'instant d'en
recevoir les images propose à maurice ce
werther de commenter le petit passage
consacré au salvador six en tout cas là
ou bien si la sécurité de nos opérations
militaires nous prenons toutes les
précautions possibles il y un risque et
un danger mais aucun niro combani
n'accompagnera des troupes salvadorienne
au combat ils seront aussi en sécurité
s'il est possible de l'aisne dans ce
pays
ils resteront dans les garnisons ils
entraîneront l'armée chenet je regrette
de dire qu'on ne peut pas dire qu'il n'y
a aucun risque bien l'esprit mais nous
faisons un maximum pour assurer leur
sécurité
donc je retiens d'être confiance parce
que le plan ryan confirme à nouveau
qu'il n'envisageait pas d'envoyer au
salvador des troupes de combat
américaines
et puis pour terminer tout à fait ce
journal une belle histoire une histoire
d'amour de peinture et disent enchantés
un habitant de thonon les bains qui
s'est aperçu en faisant des travaux chez
lui qu'il avait un véritable petit
chef-d'oeuvre des tableaux étaient
tombées de ses murs sous les coups des
ouvriers alors il a fait venir un expert
pour constater les dégâts en essuyer un
petit coin d'une prétendue croûte et
puis on a découvert
nous on attend du beau gain un tableau
qui représentait une tahitienne peinte
sur un vieux carton une tahitienne qui
est à elle seule toute une histoire
laurent massardier vous la raconte
compactes et sous les bras de cet homme
une véritable fortune vraisemblablement
un milliard de centimes
sous ce vieux journal un souvenir celui
d'une escale à bora bora
lorsqu'il était marin il ya 25 ans sur
la jeanne d'arc souvenir d'une jeune
femme d'une jeune tahitienne de 18 ans
marie louise qui le tenait elle même de
sa grand mère
on sait dire au revoir
et puis cela que ce miracle aurait
qu'elle est partie en courant jusqu'à sa
sac à dos à sa satisfaisons qui
s'appelle un phare et ou une forêt et
les revenus en courant également ça a
mis trois minutes 4 minutes c'est tout
puisque je lui ai demandé vous ouverture
on va on parle pas tout de suite et leur
mue avec un papier sous-le-bois elle
avait tout simplement le tableaux de
gauguin que vous avez tué à la place
qu'il a occupée pendant un certain temps
en le paiement du papier épais peu genre
papiers américains
elle m'a de décembre disant tiens tiens
va t'en tiens
et quand j'ai ouvert mon papier j'ai vu
mon tableau je me suis mis à pleurer
quand même c'est comme ça que j'ai eu à
l'eau est-ce que vous avez vu que c'est
un goût du risque de vie lui la
signature de gauguin moi quand je voyais
sage déjà jarry en est pour ainsi dire
pas parce que j'appréciais passe se
peint peinture ma femme par contre a
toujours été sensible au charme de ce
petit tableau le moins quand je lisais
la signature se voyaient d'un gang gens
n'avaient même jamais entendu parler
faut-il faut-il être bête d'ailleurs
j'étais absolument pas ça m'intéressait
pas si vous voulez briller m'intéressait
absolument pas est-ce qu'on se fait des
propositions chiffrées ce qu'on vous a
proposé en ce qui concerne les
propositions chiffrées
on m'a plutôt fait refait certaines
destinations des gens de l'ordre du
milliard
qu'en sera-t-il ce tableau le garder
pour le mettre au coffre le vendre mais
il craint les requins alors peut-être le
cédera-t-il au musée de papeete à charge
de lui offrir de temps en temps un
billet pour revoir ses souvenirs
voilà donc comme un gars est devenu
google
c'est gérard holtz que vous retrouverez
pour la démission vers 23 heures il roux
confirmant à ce que disait laurent
broomhead tout à l'heure à propos de la
météo demain encore de faibles pluies
surtout au nord de la loire plus de
soleil dans le sud est mais partout des
températures 12 quand même demain
antenne de midi recevra le comédien
bruno cremer je vous souhaite à tous une
excellente soirée vous retrouverez
patricia charles ix à ce te place
pendant le week end samedi et dimanche
en voilà dit